E aí
como todo militante quando a entrar
militância quer mudar o mundo a gente
vai mudar o mundo mas a gente tem que
descansar a gente tem que entender a
gente tem que ver onde dói para a gente
conseguir se localizar no mundo não dá
para carregar o mundo nas costas
militante então famosa frase faz boa
descansa militante se você descansar a
gente consegue fazer tudo em conjunto
não levo muito nas costas você não vai
mudar um sozinho mas em conjunto todo
mundo Ali alinhado vai dar certo depois
de tudo que a gente passou até a gente
reconhecereis entender quem a gente é
hoje gente precisa descansar a gente
precisa entender a gente vai mudar tudo
mas com calma atropelando as coisas não
rola não fui não acontece povo Preto
descansa a luta é nossa vida é Nossa tá
tudo lindo ou melhor a gente vai deixar
tudo lindo eu tenho fé tá ligado mas não
se atropela eu quero você forte na luta
mas para isso tem que descansar descansa
militante descansa e eu falo isso do
fundo do meu coração como uma pessoa que
não Descansou um dia
tô passando por cima de mim mesma para
conseguir lutar pelo mundo e eu descobri
que não tá pelo mundo é um processo de
todos é um processo para a vida quando
eu não puder pisar mais na avenida
quando as minhas pernas não puderem
aguentar levar meu corpo junto com o meu
samba e o meu anel de Bamba entrego a
quem mereça usar é sobre não deixar
morrer não deixar acabar é sobre samba
sobre sambar é sobre letra história
sobre glória de tempo em tempo nosso
tempo vai diminuindo estreitar laços vai
muito além da militância estratégia
política eu falo de vida eu falo de
pessoas eu falo de mim mesma reconhece
no espelho poucas vezes pois o tempo ou
a falta dele fez com que eu não
conseguisse mais me admirar Como assim
sua frente mas eu falo de voz eu falo de
escuta o meu retrato Pode parecer
estranho mas a minha voz sempre será a
mesma cantando Zeca Arlindo Alcione
o clube de Quintal até passar mal o meu
autorretrato você vai esquecer um dia
mais a minha voz no samba sempre será
reconhecido na esquina repito eu falo de
vida e eu não tô falando de fama eu tô
falando de show eu tô falando de gritos
pouco espaço no bar eu falo de Skol
gelada que atrapalha quando a gente quer
bater palmas eu falo do jovem militante
que não consegue mais parar para curtir
eu tô falando da nossa galera que se
perdeu para ser Ói eu falo de quem
trabalha a semana inteira e não lembra
mais do que constrói eu falo da
auto-sabotagem o golpe que mais dói eu
falo para mostrar que a gente precisa se
cuidar e eu não tô falando de check-up
geral eu tô falando da culpa que você
traz por se achar ruim no que faz mesmo
sendo genial eu tô falando das vezes que
você sentiu é egoísta por pensar em você
eu tô falando seu psicológico porque eu
já coisa aqui magistrado você eu tô
falando de lazer eu tô falando de ir
para o samba eu tô falando de beber
cerveja eu tô falando demais de ar Bebê
vocês que você quer hoje vai lá e faz o
mundo não vai acabar porque você está
curtindo para de achar que o mundo
depende só de você não carrega tudo isso
nas costas Nossa isso cansa
a coisa a militância ela está dentro de
você no bar que mais tenha debate
político explícito e falta abrigo de
alma que o certinho se perdoe mas se for
preciso mais com uma torre de chopp em
Braga na quarta mesmo trabalhando cedo
na quinta eu quero que você tome um gole
de vida fica não se perde na deles não
fica louco com eles mas não somos como
todo mundo o medo do seu intelectual
fala comigo também me chama de feia mas
de burra nunca meu bem eles nunca vão
entender o que é estudar e trabalhar de
segunda a segunda nunca então não se
afunda revive grita olha para o lado Se
olha no espelho se toca com dois ou três
dedos e umas amigas aí faz um convite
não surta eu sou a voz na sua cabeça
falando para você não se perder na luta
me escuta eu sou as vezes que você se
perdeu sozinho eu só falta de carinho
sou eu o que sobrou O que resta então
não deixa não deixa
e não deixe o samba morrer Não deixe o
samba acabar o morro foi feito de samba
de samba pra gente sambar não se deixa
acabar favelado favelada descansa cara
descansa o mundo ele vai mudar a gente
vai mudar o mundo mas vamos com calma né
[Aplausos]
E aí